[Music]
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is always my
job to deconstruct world-class
performers of various types and across
many disciplines and today we have Liz
Lambert on the show Liz thanks so much
for taking the time so happy to be here
I am thrilled to have you finally in
front of me and I'm going to give people
a little bit of context so who is Liz
Lambert
Liz Lambert at the Liz Lambert at
Instagram and Twitter first purchased a
seedy motel on South Congress Avenue 23
years ago and transformed it into Hotel
San Jose which has become known today as
the quintessential Austin hotel the
success of Hotel San Jose which sparked
the revitalization in the cities now
thriving South Congress district which
we'll definitely talk about led her to
launch bunk house group the hospitality
company founded on the pillars of design
music and community driven experiences
since then she's expanded bunkhouses
unique hotel portfolio to include el
cosmic o which has been recommended to
me about a thousand times the community
lodging concept in Marfa also plays
worth talking about the iconic Austin
Motel a renovated motor court hotel and
hotel st. Cecelia where I was just two
nights ago in fact a 14 room secluded
estate in Austin hotel Havana Havana
depending on where you are the historic
property on San Antonio's Riverwalk and
most recently has added bunk houses
first international hotel Hotel san
cristobol Baja in todos santos mexico
and the first non texas property
domestically the phoenix hotel to their
hotel portfolio lambert and bunk house
also operate jose coffee
the popular austin coffee shop which I
frequent myself and that currently
includes three locations and an East
Side event space fair market also
located in Austin they really gave you a
full oh we're gonna hover and all the
bases lands for thousands of el the
Magdalena is currently in development
and slated to open on South Congress in
2020
maybe 2019 most say maybe 2019 Wow ahead
of schedule that's unusual I would
imagine it's a moving target and there's
so many places that we could start with
this and we have some mutual friends
which which makes me always a bit more
comfortable
and excited to jump into things but I
thought we begin with the last days of
San Jose now this is a documentary and I
hold you fully accountable for keeping
you up way past my bedtime
lots of you son I've watched most of it
haven't seen all of it I'll be honest
because I had to go to bed last night at
some point there's a surprise ending
well it's it's it's a documentary on
Hotel San Jose's origins and I thought I
would share a note from my assistant so
my assistant doesn't add notes to much
of my prep documentation at all
and this is her note quote I've watched
most of the documentary on and off
throughout the day just just listen to
her talk to the humanity of people the
San Jose it tells you everything
important you need to know about her and
I wasn't sure quite what that meant it
was seemed a bit cryptic and I have to
say a very impressed with the doc be I
you must have captured so much footage
and you did a really nice job of editing
for emotional impact I was that wasn't
me by the way okay I didn't edit and I
never could have edited that and I never
would have been in the doc had it been
my your choice could you tell people who
don't know and I imagine that's a lot of
people yeah I never released about the
doc and why didn't you release it I was
trying to find it online so I guess I
could push it out to people you know
it's terrible it is every year this is
one of those things every year it's on
my list to do and I could never quite so
this is a documentary and I'll tell you
why I talked about why I never did this
is a documentary that I did when I first
bought the San Jose which I used to be a
lawyer it was sort of a change of career
inadvertently and I bought an old motel
down on South Congress
I've terrible Austen allergies today so
sorry about that that's okay I was we
were chatting that this is audio very
truthfully i Biden in the mid 90s
I bought it in a motel down in South
Congress I was a lawyer at the time and
I'd basically just walked up to the door
knocked on the door and there was a time
a nice couple there that owned the motel
and at the time there was nothing on
South Congress which is as you know a
very popular hot spot cool area very hip
but it wasn't a car on the street back
then
I mean honestly and they were about to
put the motel on the market and I sort
of you know person I told them don't do
that yet let me see if I could do
something about it I ended up buying the
San Jose not knowing anything about what
I was doing for $500,000 my mother
co-signed a note and suddenly they
handed me the keys and I was on my way
and I knew nothing about running a hotel
or a motel or anything knew nothing
about business really no paint a picture
for people as to the clientele and what
was the kind of the state of affairs
because people think South Congress now
and they're like oh I gotta have fancy
Japanese food and I can go have a go
have some mascara I was dicey I mean
people didn't go down there at night
there were no businesses on the street
this Continental Club was there and have
been there since 1957 and it remained
but really there was no place to eat
the first Schlotzsky's was actually on
South Congress really tiny place but
there was nothing down there and I'd
moved back into the neighborhood and but
I would go to the Continental Club a lot
so sit on a barstool there and I've
watched the San Jose across the street
which was an old motor court built in
the 30s like a Spanish Colonial Revival
style painted seafoam green at the time
and it looked like it was empty but it
was really because there were people it
was full all the time but it was 30
bucks 25 to 30 bucks a night and nobody
really had luggage or cars and nobody
really came out during the day so it
looked very quiet but at night it was
teeming with life and it was you know
the reserve it was junkies and
prostitutes and but a lot of good people
too that were just down on the luck for
one reason or another
couldn't pay a deposit
first and last month's deposit or
somehow something in life had happened
that dislodged them but you know they
could get a hotel room for either a
couple of nights or some people live
there there were residents that live
there permanently but they just paid by
the day or by the week I have so many
questions I could do an hour just on
this dock and it's not obviously because
I have anything to gain financially from
pushing the dock cause it's not even
available so I was going to tell you why
it's not available yeah okay I shot the
dock which was following I as an
undergraduate I was a creative writing
major with a concentration in poetry
just for background for folks and this
is this is my my nonlinear style I
apologize where did you where did you
just a quick kind of bullets where did
you grow up and where did you do your
undergrad yeah I grew up in West Texas
and I did my undergrad I started it TCU
in Fort Worth and had a brief stint at
Stanford and then I finished at UT so
way of seeing the world and creative
writing and humanities in a very yeah so
I had a lot with the concentration in
poetry so I had a lot of friends who
were writers or who you know I wrote a
lot at the time even back then just did
whether it was journaling or poetry or
whatever it was and friends would
encourage me to write down when I
stopped my law job at some point when I
knew I knew I was in over my head or in
a good way over my head at the San Jose
but I needed to do something with the
motel I couldn't continue on at $30.00
night with people stealing sheets and
bleeding on sheets and burning sheets
you know like you name it but I people
kept encouraging me and write down
things that happened during the day cuz
it I would tell stories at dinner I'd go
to dinner with friends and it would be
absolutely absurd or you're crazy within
the first five or ten minutes you see it
yeah quite a few examples yeah so I I
didn't have time to write it down
because I was literally like you know
the place with the place had been redone
in the 70s I think was the last time so
it had shag carpet still so you can
imagine as you tried to vacuum that shag
carpet what was like I mean there were
definitely people it was definitely a
place where you did drugs it was
definitely a place where you had
whatever homeless pet you might have I
mean it was just like they were the
housekeeper that had been at the motel
before I bought it there were a husband
and wife the Sioux's who were awesome
people but they were the only employees
besides mr. Wu who I swear to God was
like two years older in God and almost
blind and he was a housekeeper so like
the state of the room God there were
just I mean a thing to behold and and I
cleaned rooms for quite a while so I was
so busy that I wasn't writing things
down there was no journaling there was
no that kind of thing but I did find a
camera it was right when those little
pocket cameras came out there was a
little Sony PC seven and I got one of
those so I just started talking to
people people knew the camera was there
I put it up the front desk had a little
glass thing that you slid money through
and I just duct taped it to the front
for a while and then when I would go out
to knock on doors or kick people out or
collect money because it wasn't like you
came and paid on a daily basis you
really I had to chase down money and so
just take it with me and when I was done
I was really lucky at the time that I
had a friend who was at AFI as in
cinematography what is a if american
film is two together
her name is jen lane and she just now is
a producer of the new queer i super
popular yeah and she was one of my good
friends and then she had a friend named
Tabriz whit's
who is a producer now as well but a very
well-known cinematographer before she
became a producer she shot the first
three three seasons of The Wire and
that's why the wire looks like it does
Wow
so they were both in film school and
they came down and I said you guys come
help me shoot because they were both
directors of photography what we're
studying and they weren't awesome
because not only do they shoot some
b-roll and then when I was ready to shut
the motel down they shot the last three
weeks but do tell
encouraged me you said audio Verte
that's exactly what she told me I was
really worried about a big microphone
and stuff but nobody would have talked
to me right you know like she was like
and don't worry about your film style
just talk to people and the story is
compelling enough and that was those
words of wisdom and as long as you could
hear it right you know it was gonna be
okay you didn't need a huge microphone
to stick in somebody's face just make
sure it was audible enough so you have
this you've some incredible footage and
I mean you really do capture I'm
searching for a word besides humanity
because it seems too high concept maybe
for for for what I'm trying to convey
but you captured the the vulnerability
and the sincerity of so many different
types of people of all different colors
of all different types who are
completely marginalized discarded these
sort of invisible people and I watched
this and I was having just a [ __ ] of a
day yesterday and I was feeling sorry
for myself and I was talking to friends
and we were commiserating about various
things and I've had a what I would
consider in my life a bit of a hailstorm
of a week and then I watched this and I
was just like you [ __ ]
God you should get down on your knees
every day and just you thank God that
you have the bed that you have to sleep
and then you have the food that you have
to eat it's it's it was really humbling
and you're holding this footage you have
these stars to be helping you why not
put it out I get busy I mean here's the
thing
I help you put this thing out let's do
that it's it's it last three years it's
been at the top of my list and I keep
having people that say they'll help and
then you know everybody's busy and so it
becomes obably um I can I will commit
right now publicly the I will help you
and puts out so happy
it's okay it's it's very as long as
you're not expecting like a a full-blown
red carpet theatrical release if you
just want it to be available to pay just
want it to be available so what happened
was right when it was done it you'll see
the the dock ends as I close the door
when we close the San Jose we follow
during the the footage what during the
documentary we follow five or six people
that are permanent residents at the San
Jose again I was just shooting on the
fly kind of keeping a video diary and so
I would turn the camera on myself every
month well I never even want to begin
editing and realize I couldn't edit it I
had 90 hours of footage I mean there's
so much good stuff in there
but there was no way I was gonna be able
to tell a story so another friend of my
friend Jones from AFI tena Gazzara whose
works in the business still today I
hired her to edit but I didn't have her
edit until about four or five years into
the San Jose being open and so it was
hilarious because she would see people
that might have passed through the
footage or the documentary and they
would have no idea who she was but she
spent hours and hours with watching them
and you know she would be hey and they'd
be like yeah you know way too much she
did an amazing job and she gave
compelling reasons that I should also be
a character in the movie because it
wasn't just about it was also about my
story and about me living there as part
of a community and the struggle I was
having and everybody had a struggle
different struggles but you know one of
the remarkable things is that they're
all behind me the folks that live there
generally so can I can I pause for a
second yeah so there are a few like
lilypad hops that I want to know more
about so first is you went to three
places for undergrad
books in creative writing with an
emphasis on poetry why did you go to
three places and how on earth you go
from there to law let's start with that
I went to three places because my family
or I I'm from West Texas my my parents
met at TCU my grandfather played
football for TCU my dad played football
for TCU my oldest brother's labor ball
for TCU everybody in the in the kind of
cousin group everybody went started at
TCU and I got there in Fort Worth as a
lovely place I'm crazy about Forth Worth
these days but I always knew it wasn't
really gonna be a fit for me and once I
kind of got interested in creative
writing the program there wasn't that
strong I went to Stanford because I
think it was aspirational what I I
thought that's where I would transfer I
went there for summer school and then I
died I was accepted into as a regular
student at Stanford and I deferred I
there were things going on with my
family that I needed to come back to
Texas and once I came back I just in
terms if you're comfortable say I mean
yes I'm sure sickness or a divorce my
parents yeah and I was really close to
my mom and so it was I felt like I
needed to be closer and I you know
deferred a semester and then I ended up
just going to UT I always loved Austin
and if you know in the long run I'm
really happy I did I mean when I arrived
in Austin and I had the early eighties
it felt like the place was made for me
you know just felt like home like what
about it you know I'm a Texan through
and through and but there were a lot of
reasons that I didn't really fit
comfortably into other parts of Texas
yeah if I was gay at the time I wasn't
even out and I was a little more
creative maybe I do I haven't found my
place in Texas except for West Texas and
you know Austin it was the state capital
the university was huge it was you know
this liberal place and a more
conservative state and the blueberries
the blueberry the tomatoes in the
domestic and then and the music was
amazing and there were rivers and lakes
and you know it's
it was I felt it felt like home for
those people who have never been to
Texas and there certainly lots of
international folks listening and they
have the they may have the image
certainly of the cowboy hat and the
boots but that's about it
when you say Texan through and through
in other respects for for you what does
that mean I'm from West Texas and you
know that's there's a lot of people that
grew up in Texas and never even make it
to West Texas is a big state for the you
guys who don't know I mean although Jeff
Bezos maybe unbeknownst to many people
it's very would be one of those be right
in the middle of West Texas is a good
place to launch a rocket ship from and
so you know it's a I think sixth or
seventh generation in the ranching
business my family still ranches cow and
calf operation and so there was a
certain way Texas Texas is like another
country for some people yeah it really
is I mean I don't look of Texas that's
right and that comes with a good and bad
but for me mostly it's it's a good thing
is there a friend of mine asked me when
I was young and traveling he said when
people if people were to ask if you were
in Europe where are you from I would say
West Texas it's like that's early on
most people wouldn't say that they would
say not only you say Texas you give the
region Oh Texas you're from like West
Texas is so different than East Texas
you know it is a enormous enormous state
yeah see you end up in Austin how does
the law come into the picture and why
I've well so as I said I was humanities
major which I'm forever thankful for and
know that I doubled down with a
concentration in poetry but just you
don't you know they're not looking for
poets out there I don't think so much
it's so I applied to go to yeah I could
go get my him I favors really the path I
was on and a graduate degree in in
writing right you know applied to one
program at Sarah Lawrence and didn't get
in and I I was like okay what now I knew
that I was gonna need a little further
education or some other direction so
actually the first thing I did is I got
an internship at Texas Monthly and
worked there for I didn't went on to
work as a as a paid I don't even know
what it was paid employee I guess
at Texas Monthly for about a year and
applied to law school during that time
my father always argued that law school
education was something I'd never be
sorry about and it was actually the best
liberal education you could get do you
agree with that now I do actually you
know I was afraid at the time that does
kill every bit of creativity in me you
know that would somehow learning to
think logically would dampen my ability
to be creative and I don't think that's
true at all see if you finished law
school mm-hmm do you work in the law
profession before Hotel San Jose I did
indeed so I went straight from law
school to the DA's office in Manhattan
and worked there for three and a half
years or so and then moved back to
Austin and worked at the attorney
general's office so I was a trial lawyer
and again something I'll never be sorry
about
I made amazing friends that I'm still in
in touch with on a regular basis from
from a text thread to occasional
reunions but it also taught me how to
think in a way that has served me really
well in business and and just in the
world it teaches you a former brigham to
be a trial lawyer to understand all the
facts of any situation and again and to
put it together
so understanding the facts then of your
situation at the time if I if I if I
contrast contrast is in the right where
it sounds too judgy
if I look at if I look at your path side
by side with the paths of other former
lawyers I know which are many a lot
right
so maybe there they say I don't want to
do law but I'm gonna do management
consulting yeah I don't want to do law
I'm going to start a company with my
friend or go to business school there
aren't many who say I don't want to do
law I'm gonna buy a hotel that's that's
full of drug addicts and prostitutes and
so on so why that particular choice how
did that how did that come to pass yeah
I think partially was serendipity um I
was in the right place at the right time
on the right Street what appealed about
it to you cuz moat I mean for a lot of
people that would be it would have the
they would have a repellent effect you
would have an attractive well if you
think about it
they come from the DA's office and a lot
of the work I did was with a lot of this
same I don't know exactly where that
concentric circle is but you know a lot
of the people I dealt with in New York
and in the criminal justice system that
whether it was from a police ride-along
or just looking at the stories of people
every day
down and out orient with in trouble or
you know with when things get cross in
one way or the other in their lives was
not something new for me in that way and
I wasn't scared of that you know junkies
and hookers and you know they like I
said again there were a lot of really
good people there but were at a moment
in their lives just really clear in the
dock yes part of the reason why yeah
it's gonna get really that's right but
there were a lot of people hustling and
whether it be a good hustle or a bad
hustle and I'm a big believer in
hustling but there was some pretty I got
there are some pretty good grifters in
there as well but so it wasn't
unfamiliar milieu for me but I always
was interested in design it's something
that I had always enjoyed and my brother
one of my brother's was it worked for
ICF international contract furnishings
kind of like Noll
and was I wish I knew no no no like I
know is a business that makes that
probably started in mid century it was
known for Florence Knoll and may issued
a lot of classic furniture that you
would see and you know like Mies van der
Rohe did stuff for know Lord got it okay
design he was in design I should say and
so it's a world that I was always
fascinated by and it there was really
not this clear path it was I and I've
also always been interested you disliked
law I am you know I I actually really
liked the DA's office
I liked criminal law a lot I've there's
a line in a Carolyn forshay poem where
she says there's nothing no man won't do
to another and that's fascinating to me
like why we do what we do and why does
our criminal justice system do what it
does and respond to the human condition
the way it does and you know what are
our rules and laws I found that
fascinating and I also liked trial work
I like talking to a jury I'd like to I
liked the whole not just pageant of it
but the actual truth finding mission I
like also like I liked being a lawyer
where it wasn't a lot of people think
that at the DA's office there their
whole purpose is to get a conviction or
you know be an arm of the police in one
way or the other and it's not it's
really to do justice or to do the right
thing and that's an amazingly powerful
thing you know a lot of people with my
politics would have probably gone to the
public defender's office can you explain
why that's the case
well because why is that the case why do
people with more liberal politics go to
the public defender's office I think
that the the DA's office is often seen
to be in a lot of the pit bull
yeah and in in alignment with police the
police and you know you've got a to do
you know to fight the good fight you've
got a
the person that that is on the side of
on the side of justice in the way of
making sure that the constitutional
principles are upheld and you're down in
the trenches with folks that often are
sometimes wrongly accused and so it
tends to separate out that way but at
the time I really thought when I was in
law school and thinking about going to a
DA's office that it made sense to go to
the place that had the power in the
prosecutor's office is the place where
you can choose to bring a case or not
right I was also the first openly gay
person hard at Manhattan DA's office
1991 yeah crazy
I don't want plenty of queers there yeah
first up openly oh yeah
openly and so the first year that I was
there we actually marched and the
Manhattan Gay Pride Parade like right
behind the the police department and in
front of the fire department and my
girlfriend at the time was she worked at
the minority task force on aids so of
course she was like marching with the
house of Africa and they were like
having a blast and I was there with the
DA's office the police in the fire
department
she'd be like come March with us and
she's like no but yeah so that was a you
know and there was a lot of things that
I you know you could talk for hours
about that and you know what I learned
and and yeah I guess I'm just curious
why why stop I mean a lot of people stay
in law for a very very long time so you
did have this moment here at the
Continental Club you see Hotel San Jose
across the street you have this deep
interest in design you have empathy for
the people who are mostly not seen right
when doors during the day they're right
you have all of that but you also have
this potentially safe career in the
legal profession right so why stop well
there were a couple of jumps between
there but so I stopped at the days of us
uhit's
your commitment and so I stopped about
three and a half years in right before
you go in the homicide chart I think it
an ear for that came back to Texas I
think if you stand New York too long you
become a New Yorker yes speaking with
someone raised in Long Island have to be
careful about that
you have to be very very careful yeah
you don't want that that happened to you
so I came back here and worked at the
attorney general's office and that was a
little bit different I was traveling all
over Texas trying cases and and it
wasn't as fascinating to me but I still
liked being a lawyer and I hate but I
need a couple things happened a friend
of mine died of aids-related causes and
that was a real jolt to the system it
was one of those moments where it was I
felt you better do what you want to do
and not what you're supposed to do or
you know this is your one life and your
one chance it's so I think I think that
probably happens for a lot of people you
face mortality up close for the first
time and that's either you just kind of
push it away or if you really invite it
in and and and grapple with it I think
it's a life changing thing it's so it
was for me it made me I always wondered
about the San Jose down on South
Congress and I would look at it and kind
of dream about it a little bit but that
was the the that was the thing that got
me out of the chair and across the
street and knocking on the door to find
out if they'd ever sell it and we could
we could spend the entire conversation
just on the first few months of easily
the first month the first day of your
experience at San Jose and I'm
struggling with where to go to next
looks like I don't want to stay there
but but maybe what what I can do is in
sitting right here is talk about
Christopher Alexander and certainly the
other authors but I'm curious how you
found your footing
and your approach to doing what you now
do I see you kind of land there all
right
oh my god you're doing every possible
job I mean you're using a brush to take
some god-awful stuff out of a sink I
couldn't even identify what the sludge
was you don't know like yeah you don't
want to know I mean syringes and I mean
you you're doing every job imaginable
how do you figure out your PlayBook and
when does when does when does
Christopher Alexander not to overweight
the importance of of these books but for
those people who are watching you can
see this is a book called a pattern
language towns buildings construction
which has come up a surprising number of
times in this podcast has it it has yeah
yeah interesting well so at the time I I
thought that I was going to take the San
Jose which was a 24 room motor court
built in the 30s down on South Congress
an area of town that was it was still
pretty abandoned it was one of those
places that in not unusual at the time
that there were urban cores that when
highways had come in it had redirected
traffic and the small kind of
mom-and-pop stores and urban downtown's
were bypassed but there you know
obviously there was a lot of interesting
architecture still or buildings that
that were because they were older or and
built at a time where they were on a
really important Avenue so Congress for
those of you guys who don't know is a
main thoroughfare in Austin that leads
directly to the State Capitol and at one
time it was the main avenue that went
all the way to San Antonio probably 60
miles to the south and so it was a major
thoroughfare so there were a lot of old
buildings and businesses historic and
otherwise along the way so I thought
that I would just redo this 24 room
Hotel Motel what I didn't realize was it
was 30 bucks a ninth that if I were my
idea was maybe it could be $75
and we could just redo it room by room
and then it would be this amazing place
close to downtown I had lots of friends
that would you know from musicians to
creative people to people that were
going to visit their friends in the
neighborhood that would stay there
once I started trying to crack that plan
a little bit I realized it was a
marketing nightmare the most people that
were gonna pay 60 75 bucks were on the
highway and they wanted something that
they can rely on like a motel 6 and I
was you know if I did learn somebody
downtown and done to South Congress
where there were no other hotels they
weren't gonna want to stay next to the
crackhead next to the mom-and-pop on
their van didn't want to rent next to
somebody with an arrest for warrant for
murder I weren't out for murder so I
mean it was true you saw a little bit of
the doctor the police were mean I
remember when the police first came
David Drive around the San Jose because
there was a big courtyard that was just
a parking lot and when I first got there
was like no no don't do that that looks
bad for business and by you know is
there a week and I was like can you guys
come more often so it started to realize
and I would go and get new things and
kind of try to redo the rooms one by one
and I get something new and it would be
stolen or I would get a you know like it
just wasn't gonna work room by room I
finally realized yeah there was some
footage also and we're like what
happened to the TV like the TV is
destroyed and like oh yeah the last
person who's in your left a gift for the
new person every one of these is a
[ __ ] mess but they're saying it's a
[ __ ] mess let's see what's in here
it's like oh you know it's one of those
things is it is if you clean something
up people are much more like if you
respect people people are much more
likely to respect a place or a thing or
a person and they people that were
living there I mean it was you know the
bed the mattress was bed springs that
were you know cutting you at night
sometimes so it wasn't like of course
you were gonna like throw a TV out the
window you know it was a cycle that was
that
I'd really and now I had this place now
I was trying to keep it afloat I had to
have a plan in my plan at 24 rooms with
not much money wasn't going to work and
then I started going to banks to see if
I could you know I I had gotten through
school without even taking a math class
you know and so now suddenly I needed to
understand the basics of business and
writing a business plan and I couldn't
read a spreadsheet I didn't I couldn't
read the financial statement I didn't
know what you know all those small
numbers meant and suddenly it was became
really important that I learned that
skill and so I went audited some classes
at the business school at University of
Texas has a great business school and I
took some management in the service
industry classes and have tried it
finally worked my way through how to do
a business plan it was so hard
you know I do it we do them all the time
now and we you know do studies and we do
market studies and you know it's it's a
skill that I rely on as we look at
different hotels and different markets
now we do it all the time and it was
such a foreign language to me so then I
finally got through a business plan and
I was had to go try to convince some
banks that they should loan me a bunch
of money to redo this motel on South
Congress which at the time you couldn't
convince a lot of locals Stephen set
foot on the South Congress at night much
less spend the night down there yeah so
it was a process what I what happened
this is a cliffhanger
I finally got I finally took on some
partners that believed a bit and and in
the idea and so that gave me some they
had some track record so that gave me
some legitimacy so how on earth you
convinced the first person cuz been so
thanks for saying thanks but no thanks
yeah what people were intrigued though
so I could get you know remember I was a
lawyer and so I was just really selling
it and there was a change afoot in
Austin you could fill it in the air
people were starting to return
that neighborhood there was it was a
time that it was in the mid nineties and
there was starting to be some urban
infill downtown and so I was right on
the edge of of that being not completely
implausible but it didn't help that I
had absolutely zero experience running a
business I mean that's what really got
the bank's they're like what like no I
can do that a promise look at my poetry
resume so it took a local bank at the
end of the day the guy named Eddie
saffet II who was at its now prosperity
Bank
it was Liberty at the time basically to
underwrite it but it also was remarkably
inexpensive the work we did in the in
the bigger picture is something that we
would never get away with now but I was
there all day every day it was really
lucky to have like play-doh the
architecture firm out of San Antonio now
also out of Austin to be my partners and
believe in the project as well so I hate
to bother you with just halting the
story and jumping into the nitty-gritty
but these are such important inflection
points if you don't get the money
ostensibly not good things
oh now proceed from there so we're
talking about Liberty and then
prosperity both good words how do you
convince that person how did you
convince him what was the conversation
where they're like okay how's it I mean
I also applied for an SBA loan and a
finally got it was partially funded by
the SBA so that that was great I have a
business partner now that I'm still in
business with who is a great guy and it
had a lot of experience in business and
his wife had brought him the pro forma
for the San Jose how did she get it from
a friend of a friend basically it got
passed around so you're just yeah
totally just in case let me get these
into circulation exactly again I didn't
know what I was doing right I didn't
know yeah so it was just who knew who
and she brought it home I wanted to him
and he he still has the copy of it
because when when it showed that we
would get a hundred and ten dollars a
night in year three or so he wrote in
the margin of the Performa no way he
totally didn't believe but I don't know
I you know I'm tenacious and all right
I I don't know how I finally convinced
the bank again they did take a leap I'm
sure there was some kind of personal
guarantee that I'd even know what a
personal guarantee was at the time I'm
not sure take it take my blood I mean at
that point I thought about selling the
San Jose I probably took two years to
really closed about it 95 we closed in
97 to December of 97 just start
renovation so it had taken all that time
I quit my law job just just to go try to
find money to do some kind of renovation
and in the meantime we decided to say
just just so I'm clear it said you were
doing your law hub simultaneous with
running the San Jose up to that point in
the beginning and then at some point I
realized I had to go work behind the
front desk and I quit my LA job which
was crazy too you know I have to give it
[ __ ] you know my mother has been gone
for about five years now but I can't
believe that they didn't think that was
a craziest present you I'd ever done I
mean like making no money my father
would have pointed out that it was just
at the point I became a really good
trial lawyer that I just jumped ship you
know which I mean I guess you know I
don't know even in hindsight I don't
know but I did say that I felt compelled
in some way again I'm really dogged and
really you know I'm gonna follow it down
once I decided that that's what I wanted
to do but I gotta say there were nights
I don't know why is it always nights
that I laid awake and really thought
about selling the San Jose I'm probably
two or three times I got really serious
about it I thought there's no way I'm
ever gonna be able to do this
it's too hard and I just somehow powered
through
why didn't you saw who would bought it
right see so you finally get the money
you closed for renovations what do you
do is there anything that you did that
you no longer do were the things that
you did where you're like oh that
actually became part of my palate as an
artist so to speak yes and yes in the to
both I mean there there are ways that it
was extremely inefficient that nobody
would ever let me do what I did then now
but you know was it was I was learning
on the job
it was also really low risk I mean we
think about it we look in the hotel
business you look at the price you pay
perky when you talk about selling or
buying a hotel key yeah percocet perky
perky per room per room so the the
general notion is when you're talking
about what a hotel is selling for what
you're into it for what you can develop
it for whether it's a good deal you
taught you take the total price of the
project from the land all the soft costs
all the hard costs all the working
capital everything you have in it to get
the doors open all the furnitures
fixtures equipment put that in a bucket
and divide it by the number of rooms and
that gives you the price per key of what
the hotel cost if that makes sense yeah
so I we were into the San Jose at the
day we opened the doors for $100,000 per
key which is super inexpensive if
inexpensive inexpensive at the at the
end of the day so it was low risk I mean
and I was on the front lines I'm sure
again I had a personal guarantee and I
was there every day working like crazy
and like Flatow the the architecture
firm that I've worked with repeatedly
since or they were also there every day
and so again okay the question was
are the things that I did then that I
would never do again and then are there
things that I did then that became part
of my palette yes and in looking back on
it I think what I did intuitively there
is something that we do as an
organization on a regular basis now
whenever we're looking at a hotel and
that is to say that I was interested in
what the neighborhood wanted and needed
in something the the place had been
there since the 30s in in this South
Austin neighborhood and so I wanted to
look around and look at the hotels that
are most interesting to me are part of a
neighborhood or part of a community
they're the places when I was growing up
my granddad who was a rancher didn't
have an office so he would go to the
local hotel and sit in the lobby and do
business deals and you know could his
shoosh boots shined
I got his hair cut you could do that in
the lobby of a hotel it was a place
where people met and whether you were
from out of town or you were a local
oftentimes you know like a real
cornerstone of the community or real
important place to meet for the
community so those were the kinds of
things that interested me the most so
one of the first things I asked is how
do we serve this neighborhood and South
Austin and you know one of obviously the
first things when we were directly
across the street from the Continental
Club so what a musicians need and
because at the time musicians were some
of our most frequent guests when we were
thirty bucks a night because you know
they were coming through town in a van
and they were looking for a cheap hotel
and a lot of times they might be wasted
enough that they didn't notice how bad
the bed was or anything else and we
always also had people that were
spilling out of the Continental Club
sometimes late at night but and that the
neighborhood was starting to change and
people were starting to buy
homes downtown again or in travel
science we also started a coffee shop
that opened my brother and I did months
before the San Jose opened and that
again was a need of the community so
you're looking to fill the need that's
what drove it it wasn't we want to make
a coffee shop it is what do people need
people need a coffee shop let's do a
coffee shop more than that we needed a
coffee shop this is really I want to
underscore this because it comes up so
frequently in people who ultimately
succeed in some capacity and
entrepreneurship is it so often starts
with scratching their own itch mm-hmm
and at least that way you know you have
a market of one complete speculation not
to interrupt but no when you think of a
pattern language you think of
Christopher Alexander what I was doing
intuitively this gigantic book those on
audio they're right and Zig it's it's
big you bludgeon a badger with it but
[Laughter]
the what I was doing intuitively was a
lot of what and for those of you who
don't know Christopher Alexander is as a
writer and a thinker about architecture
and about how we build and in more than
that but for me he wrote a book called a
timeless way of building which I have
not written down in a wrote a pattern
language which was basically his idea
was looking at all the old villages and
towns and communities that were you know
throughout the world that have been
there for centuries and his point was
that people figure out how to build
intuitively more so than current at the
time and probably today current
architects today who were responding to
how the thing looks rather than how it
functions and he's his argument is or
his thesis is that we know intuitively
you know where to put a fireplace or a
hallway
or you know a hub-and-spoke model in a
small community because if it's it's
those ways of building that make a place
feel more whole and more complete and
makes you as a person feel more whole
and complete is sort of he calls it and
I think he causes the quality without a
name yes I was so good the quality
without a name what does that mean well
what does it refer to well you know
those places that you've been to that
buildings you've been in or places
you've been in where it just feels right
and it feels calming rather than
agitating it feels like you are part of
something in a and in a bigger sense and
I think you know part of that would be
you know today we people design things
today this happens all the time that
they've never even been to the place
where the Tuscan village in the suburbs
is going to be put you know like you
know his argument is that you look
around you and you see how things are
built in the place you are and you look
at you don't bring building materials
that would never exist in a place you
look at the ways of doing things that
have been done for a long time and that
way you become the fabric of the place
itself yeah this book is so
simultaneously intimidating it is and
fascinating I mean I just turned to
random page 599 activity pockets and
there's a diagram with the average
number of people area of a 150 people to
300 oh no he must mean something else
300 something square feet and it's
looking at the placement of umbrellas
and what looks like an Italian Pavilion
there's another section yeah a pocket of
activity which bulges into the square
with a picture from Italy and then
there's a separate section I was
actually looking at this because I had a
cabin construction project not too long
ago and there's a section on the
integration of outside and inside right
well okay so I don't think the book
actually
I think you're reading it in the right
way meaning you should not sit down and
read that book from Catholic my god I
mean it really is something that is you
know he became he and he's still around
today but he became software what would
you say it is designer of software his
ideas about patterns and so patterns are
a thing that happens over and over again
you see in the natural order of things
so if you're talking about an Italian
Plaza where the umbrellas are think of
in your head how many times you've seen
that well there's a reason that there
there's a reason people on the ground
design that themselves because that's
where human activity went to when we
were doing a Cosmo cow which is
described that because L cosmic Co has
probably been recommended to me by
Texans more than any other hotel and
then there are Austinites who do
staycations at some of your places but
let's describe L cosmic Oh because when
when I did the introduction how did I
describe it but but I think the the
community lodging concept so what did
what when you were designing L cosmic oh
I don't well interrupt but no that's
quite a ride I chose Macau is a now 21
acres in Far West X's which in in the
city of Marfa town of Marfa Marfa is one
of the darkest places it is also about a
mile high about as high as Denver and it
is more clear nights in clear days than
your average place so you and it's one
of the there's no real the there's very
little light because it's such a sparse
area of the country means light
pollution and yeah yeah so if you think
about it there's two main counties out
in Far West Texas Brewster and Presidio
and there's something like you can fit
like 17 Rhode Island's into one of those
counties and the I forget what the
number is but the per capita the acreage
per capita per person but that's a
redundant but is enormous like you have
every person has something like
Foursquare mouths yeah that's just like
sparsely-populated him not not a lot of
cloud cover and not a lot of light
pollution might be it so for that reason
my understanding is that astronomers or
amateur astronomers but with nearly
professional-grade equipment or
professional equipment travel from all
over the country to go specifically to
Marfa that's true for the new moon and
things like that
yeah it's a I mean it's incredible you
can see the Milky Way which when I was
growing up we could you could Regulus -
the Milky Way and how often do you see
it now in places that aren't like Marfa
or like Baja California or you just weed
there's too much light pollution we just
don't see that anymore and you forget
what an amazing feeling that is in the
order of things to see another galaxy so
you have 21 acres okay so I digress
there's 21 acres we're right on the edge
of Marfa it's a town of about 2,400
people and I had done a small motel in
Marfa and it called the Thunderbird and
walked away from it was bad partnership
we it wasn't going anywhere and I but I
did know that I've won it was interested
in Marfa as a community Marfa as a
community might get my family ranches in
the region I'd moved back from New York
I'd really wanted to spend more time in
for West Texas and Martha was a little
bit on fire if you can say that for a
community of 2,400 people because Donald
Judd who is you know one of the 20th
century's most renowned sculptors was
had made a home in Marfa and it had
become an art mecca for a lot of folks
so you have this crazy mix of artists
and creative people and ranchers and
people that work on the land in this
beautiful place that for those of you
guys who are from overseas might think
of it as the myth of the American West
when you see those when you've seen
giant or you've seen
movies westerns the the landscape we're
talking about looks a lot like that just
stretching on forever antistick clouds
so a cosmic oh I bought this pasture
basically that was on the edge of town
and I wanted to build a hotel or a
lodging experience of some sort there
and I realized that it needed to be
indoors and outdoors because that's one
of the reasons you go out there and I
didn't know exactly what I was gonna do
again at the time but realize that old
trailers vintage trailers were a great
way to get started putting hotels rims
up quickly and so I'd bought but I
bought a few trailers and we redid them
and I started falling in love with
trailers of that of the like 50s 60s
time period because those old Spartans
and vagabonds and things like that are
made with this beautiful birch interior
it was before they were making air
streams with I'd you know I don't even
know what the walls of Interior and
Airstream are but they trailers of that
vintage have these beautiful wooden
interiors I mean you felt like you were
in the belly of a ship or in a ship's
cabin and they finished him with a yacht
varnish at the time and so it was this
it was like these we put the first few
trailers out there it was like ships on
the desert you know and and I just fell
in love with the whole notion of these
kind of nomadic ways of living and so we
got some yards eventually we got teepees
we've safari tents and it became this
grand experiment to see how we would use
the land so all of these all of the
rooms were moveable and so we kind of
lived our way into it that comes back to
Christopher Alexander and a pattern
language it was really starting to have
music festivals and parties there and
people living out there to determine
what did the place need and how would
people use it
so we've been talking about the outside
inside integration and Christopher
Alexander gives some great contrasting
photographs for illustrative purposes
it seems based on the homework that I've
done at least that you also think a lot
about I'll quote here and the internet
missed quotes a lot so you can correct
me if I'm wrong but it's here's here's
the quote and this is part of a longer
conversation of course but I hate it
when I visit a hotel that hasn't put
thought into the products they place in
their room it's all part of the language
of the place and the details that affect
the guests experience there so if we if
we look at al cosmic o or you could
choose a different example what are the
things that people might notice in
inside inside and outside and outside
yeah you know for I think for us at
bunkhouse part of it is a whole
experience like being at a hotel should
be and you think of some of your
favorite hotels it's not that you liked
the bedspread or it was close to the
highway you might have liked both those
things but I think probably the places
you like the most are the most immersive
and you I think of it as storytelling in
a way so every hotel that we do has
everything from a soundtrack to
oftentimes of color or a color scheme
that that repeats throughout a smell an
incense usually I get the st. Cecilia we
put nug chomp on big sticks of knock
Champa in the garden so as you're
walking through the courtyard
it's really subtle but it's something
that strikes your senses and you'll
remind you of the Saints of all the
smells that you could possibly choose
why did you choose that the Saint
Cecilia is a small hotel we have off
further back in the neighborhood off of
South Congress it's very good selection
of tequila also it's it's only 14 rooms
but it was a the main part of the st.
Cecilia is an old Victorian that was
built in the 1890s and then it has some
bungalows that are scattered around
about an acre and a carafe of land and
in order for us to do a hotel for me
there has to be a skeleton a story that
everything is hung upon or proceeds from
and so my business part is a time we
were looking at the Saints it came up
for sale it wasn't the Saints it was
just no Victorian on an acre of land
near downtown Austin and he's like
what's a story here you know if like you
had to describe this to somebody and for
me I mean it was I always loved that
whole period of rock and roll that was
about going to really nice hotels and
the super decadence not the throwing the
TV out the window but you know great
silver and the slightly tarnished Ben
the white tablecloth from room service
and the contrast of you know Dylan
taking tea somewhere or you know
drinking a bottle of whiskey the stones
at nel cot just that there's something
so awesome about where elegance kind of
meets rock and roll and said there was
this Victorian and I felt like that I'd
seen a photograph of like maybe it was a
stone's somewhere in like full-on 1970s
awesome you know clothing and there was
a chauffeur you know washing a Bentley
in the background kind of thing and so
this place where those things met
immediately became the st. Cecilia to me
and the Saints to say he was a patron
saint of music and poetry and so if you
ask where knock trumpet comes from it's
like that that smell of knock Champa is
the is the hippie smell of that time and
in putting it in a place as elegant as
the st. Cecilia makes perfect sense to
me so many questions I would think of
myself
in general as at least an aspiring
minimalist when it comes to certain
aspects of design and
certainly have very very limited
experience compared to someone like
yourself but have have had projects one
in San Francisco before I moved to
Austin where this place was stripped
down to the studs and just became an art
project and I've spent a lot of time in
Japan so it was sort of a combination of
like a green and green esslyn type feel
plus Japanese and it's a very simple in
some respects and I have a particular
dislike of clutter I guess even though
it's a ongoing battle in my own house
say I think is your brother who said the
following and you can correct me if I'm
wrong but let people be the color in the
room could you expand on that or explain
what that means it was my brother Linden
um some of the best advice ever um I
think that you know you look in hotels
at any point I mean particularly you
know last twenty thirty years I look at
someplace and I'm not given a bad shout
out but you know the loft or something
or that indigo and they think design is
fun and whimsical and it is but oh my
god how do you sleep in a play how do
you walk through the hallway you're just
assaulted by so many different patterns
and so many different like what people
think is like cool or hip or you know
now and it's just like a constant
onslaught and to me the best hotels or
the best places or places that are more
calming and so doing things through
massing or through a pattern where you
you know take the language of a place
and repeat it and repeat it and repeat
it
it may be so subtle that no that people
don't really notice but I think if you
give people a par own lives are so
cluttered in so many ways but if you
strip away everything to a certain
degree and let the people be the color
in the room it's infinitely more
interesting I think people feel better
about everything that way as well you
know when the San Jose is was the first
hotel I did and
we kind of think of it as Mexico means
Japan is for you guys who don't know
it's um we did a real sort of minimalist
job on the place and at the time we just
we developed a furniture system that
would work in in the rooms because all
the rooms were very different over the
years they've been cut up in different
ways so we needed something where we
could use something repeatedly through
home and we ended up using some pine
loblolly pine which is a local issue
from East Texas and in sort of a Judd
like way
Judd being the morph a minimalist
although I know he would hate the word
minimalist but um which I think the Judd
is very informed by Schindler and I
don't know if you know Schindler
Schindler is an architect from the 20s
that was working in the LA area but very
influential and with a very simplicity
and so the San Jose has concrete floors
where we took out walls we put in an
aggregate so you could see where the
walls used to be could you explain what
that means yeah so when um have old
cement or concrete floor a lot of times
when you remove a wall you'll have a
hole in the floor so what we would do is
we'd take a concrete mixed with rock and
fill it in and then and then sand it so
there was instead of trying to fit in
with the existing floor you could
actually see the remains of the
footprint of the dynastar exactly and so
the San Jose though although it's very
simple with just wood and concrete and
some people would think of as cold
there's a ton of plantings ton of
gardens its Fez feels really lush and
feels sort of like living indoors and
outdoors but um when it we have comment
cards and early on I really paid a lot
of attention to comment cards and I'm
sure the staff does now but one of my
favorite ones that I had up on the wall
for a while was somebody had written
this is the most expensive [ __ ]
garage I've ever seen
[Laughter]
so what do you do in response to
something like that or do you not are
you like you know not everyone's gonna
get it and that's okay it's really hard
at first because not everyone was gonna
get it and you have to decide if you
want to please everybody or if you just
keep doing what you're doing and know
that intuitively there's something that
you will find your audience and again I
was very lucky in life to be in the
right place at the right time because
Austin was changing and when we first
opened in San Jose now just did not
discount your skillset completely I mean
you're in the right place at the right
time but you've also now how many how
many properties do you have it may be
eight yeah yeah
so I mean once you're lucky twice you're
good eight times okay but continue yeah
okay so buddy
you know but at that time with the first
project you don't know what you don't
know and you don't know I have a lot
more confidence now
right I mean I had confidence then but
not necessarily as a designer but I
remember we first open we opened we
opened in March which is a spring break
but it's also South by Southwest which
is a huge conference you used to be more
music centric but now it's tech and film
and a lot of people descend on Austin
there's not a it's got to be I don't
know the exact size now but it's got to
be fifty to a hundred thousand yeah so
tell room in town well we sort of did a
soft opening which is crazy but what
does that mean soft opening is where you
invite people to that you that might be
friendly towards you or at a very
discounted price to a property or a
restaurant and let let the staff
practice on you knowing there's going to
be some mistakes so suited your South
opening during South but right before it
was like February 14th and I remember
February 14th was the first day that we
had in so it was Valentine's they had
anybody that actually can spent the
night in the hotel and I would put a
banner outside that we sold rooms for
$69 for Valentine's Day
and so that was a special and I mean
like trying to just get people in the
doors was was the whole point
we opened you're in South by Southwest
totally sold out crazy because of course
we had something in the something was in
the waste pipe that was going to the
street like an electrical fixture
falling down into it so entire wing of
the hotel flooded with sewage you know
people were running out of the hotel
with her stand-up bass or you know
whatever there's no place to put them
but alright so it's in the middle of
South by complete chaos yeah everything
is stretched to max capacity yeah I'm
sure that stress is running high for a
lot of people who have flown in to
perform or whatever so you have sewage
flooding halfway how do you handle that
I don't know I mean you know you you
have to be on the frontlines of it and
putting rubber boots and the whole thing
and again really you know I don't know
is its hospitality yeah yeah usually
people don't know this but behind the
scenes so we you a lot of places over
booked knowing because they're counting
on cancellations just like Airlines yeah
exactly and so you hotels you know
hospitality business is really
interesting because hotels really are
behind the scenes usually most likely
want to be friends with each other you
know you can say it's competition but
you're sharing information all the time
yield management and what's going on in
town and you just so you know rising
tide raises all boats to a certain
degree but you're also gonna have to
walk somebody sooner or later to another
hotel which means that you're gonna
you're gonna pay for their room
somewhere else because you've either
overbooked or missing her head sewage
for the rooms yeah but there was no
hotels to mark anybody I don't know how
I managed to put it out of my mind now
you've blocked it but if you try to
unblock it those there any what do you
say did you get them to stay they're not
sleeping on the street presumably so I
think we did get him to stay I think
that we went in and cleaned like crazy
and disinfected like crazy and remade
the rooms all hands on deck completely
you come
I just can't yeah totally you know they
say in the service industry a good
recovery is gonna make a bigger more
loyal guest then if you hadn't [ __ ] up
at all
that's general yeah that's very true cuz
you'll tell ten people if somebody
really makes something right right well
I mean that because everybody's all
smiles and high-fives when everything is
going smoothly it's like how do they
handle things and do they own the
problem when things go sideways on their
watch kind of hard not to own that one
was it that is hard not to own that one
how dare you flood your own room assuage
chip Conley chip Conley is someone we
both know chip if you're if you're
listening or somebody passes this along
miss you would love to see you it's been
a long time since I've spent time with
chip but I've heard you describe him as
a mentor I don't know if that if you if
or I haven't heard you have read it so
who knows it's accurate but could you
describe for folks who don't know the
name who is Chip and what what have you
learned or gleaned or observed from show
huh that's so much over the years I'm
chip is a mentors to this day I saw him
last week for those of you guys who
don't know chip started a hotel company
called joie de vivre that was based in
San Francisco and he started when he was
fresh out of business school probably
early 20th the Phoenix was his first
hotel which was a motor court not unlike
the San Jose or the Austin motel and was
a favorite of bands on tour musicians
that kind of thing
chip continued to grow a very successful
hotel company and decided at some point
in his around 50 or so I don't know how
was chip when he sold you out of Yves
I'd have been might have been right
afterwards I remember I was at chips we
didn't talk about this Burning Man camp
I understood oh yo no kiddin he's a we
were totally was right so was it Maslow
topia yeah so I was that's the only time
I've ever been to brands really I would
they have one of the yurts that was um
of course I did that's wild all right so
we were at the same camp and Burning Man
it just didn't bump into each other or
maybe we did who at the who knows like
the catered chip food which by the way I
mean it was such a conscious my first
experience not digress too too far but
my first experience at Burning Man was
trying to build the geodesic dome with
my friend on the spot that we had put
together based on internet instructions
when I was in San Francisco
and then realizing none of it would fit
together we've ran out of water the RV
we had broke downs the air conditioning
didn't work it was just it was absolute
survival mode and university and then I
came to two shifts and I was like oh my
god this is like the four seasons of I
mean like he really he did the whole
camp with some friends and basically you
could get food at any point you wanted
there was a full-service bar I had an
air-conditioned you're in him you know
it was only like six feet across and it
was made out of some kind of building
but it was like fold up the whole thing
folded up into a very small package
whose but it wasn't a bad way I kind of
in and out yeah that's why I came flew
over there at the same time so so he
sold he's around he's yeah so drive Eve
he's still a very young man by the way
if you're listening chip and he the guys
from Airbnb tap demons children said
come help us a little bit and what was
helping in an advisory role for a while
he became the head of global hospitality
for Airbnb and along the way he's
written a lot of great business books
that we often have our managers read and
like peek and the the emotional equation
what is that book yeah you know well if
people I'm blanking on the title but I
will tell people that chips chips been
on the on my blog a few times and if you
search how to become an effective CEO
chief emotions officer and my name or
just search Tim Ferriss chip Conley and
that'll Palmer right up with that book
right chip has written many books and he
is often is done a TED talk and is often
a lecturer on business and just on being
a more complete person and so chip
continued throughout so the way I met
chip is a CO called him
I bought the San Jose didn't know what I
was doing had no idea of what I was
gonna do and I saw his name like in a
trade magazine and so I called him up
unbelievably he called me back in about
30 minutes what was it do you live
voicemail I I think I did I don't
remember exactly yeah I think I did
leave a voice on how I got his number
what would you said I have this motel in
South Austin and I just wanted to talk
to you about it quick or something like
this we've course that boy yeah of
course I think he thought I wanted to
see if he wanted to consider buying it
but the fact that he called me back was
I have cursed him for from this from
that day to this day because now people
constantly you know now they email me or
some way asked if I could spend a few
minutes and for advice and you know that
just aren't the hours in the day but he
just pops up in my brain every time like
what would have happened had he not
called back you know and I don't know
but I'm over the years he was one of the
first guests San Jose he was passing
through and he came to see it after
giving advice and I went met him in San
Francisco he looked at my numbers that I
didn't really understand and tried to
make sense of them but I could have had
that commerce a have that conversation
now much better I'm and then most
recently we have a hotel in Baja
California in a little town called todos
santos right outside a little town
called todos santos that is about 45
minutes from Cabo and he is the one that
got me into that because he had sold his
hotel company and was not I I don't know
if he had a non-compete or just not
supposed to be in the business and he
was very interested in the community and
so he kind of pointed them in my
direction and now we have really great
hotel there and chip lives part of his
life in tennis on toast now what what
other best practices
or principles or donots or dues have you
picked up from from chip or other people
well actually our head our president now
at bunkhouse I work for chip for 10
years a guy named Christians trouble and
you know it's good here's the thing you
can be as creative as you want to be and
dream as big as you want and create an
incredible experience and programming
and everything along those lines but if
you don't can't keep the lights on if
you can't return money to investors if
you can't keep your employees happy then
you're never gonna have a successful
business I mean you've got to keep the
lights on you know and you've got to do
a little better than keeping the lights
on but I think a lot of people fell in
business because they don't have
operational rigor and that can be a lot
of different that can manifest in a lot
of different ways but I think that chip
was influential from early on about
operations and and how important not
just your guest was but your employee
and your investor as well the chip is
and peak even as it relates to Maslow
Maslow's hierarchy of needs and hence
mezcla topia as the name of the Burning
Man camp is something that he would
apply also to these various stakeholders
mm-hm
so another mutual acquaintance Larry
McGuire of McGuire Mormon group here
many different restaurants I did Larry
to ask him you know what topics or
questions might I want to explore with
Liz and he said ah well there's so many
things we could explore it about one of
the things he brought up was the
question how do you balance and I'm
paraphrasing here but it's not that far
off how do you balance wanting the
desire to be an artist with the desire
to be say a business
right it's a really interesting question
it I mean it's such a balance I mean it
is Larry's actually very good at what he
does Larry has several restaurants here
in town and I've known Larry since he
was about 16 and started work for my
brother but Larry is one of those rare
people that understands both again rigor
and operations which is going to be
really important at the end of the day
for somebody to have the right
experience and the artistry of creating
an experience to me if you don't like
people make hotels people design hotels
and then they walk away and so that is
always going to get diluted over time if
if you don't remain involved in the
experience or what your vision was in
the first place then what you created is
it's not just an object it's a living
breathing thing that has employees
people that work there that spend their
lives there
it has guests that come and go as part
of a ever-evolving community and it has
people that have part of ownership in
the in the place so I think your vision
is not complete if you just create
something and walk away
it isn't other and other genres of art
but in a hotel or in a restaurant
it begins anew every day in a way and so
to create a guest experience that is
right for that hotel takes you know
constant vigilance in a way and and that
is always going to translate to the
bottom line I mean we don't market most
of our hotels in a certain way but
people market them for us Instagram is
obviously great and so are a lot of
other social media platforms but we get
a fair amount of print as well and that
comes a lot not for
must necessarily pitching stories but
for people becoming real believers and
what we do and so I don't know if I'm
really answering that question except to
say it's a you have to have both things
whether it's you doing it or someone
else that believes in your vision and
you believe in theirs
you've got to have both the artistry in
the beginning and the good practice to
continue in the good business practice
to continually tend the fire do you have
an idea of if you're going to be
continuing to develop hotels and put
your craft into the world in that way do
you have an idea for say how many
properties you'd like to have in five
years if you want to scale if you don't
want to scale three years doesn't really
matter I'm just wondering if you - it's
such a crossroads right now really about
this you you know the pressure and
business and the bigger business gets is
to grow grow grow and then sell it right
dance seems to be you know wonderful
look we'll be thirty years from now that
won't be the thing or if it was it
wasn't you know fifty years ago
we live in a time where it's about
growth and making your business worth as
much as you possibly can and then
selling it and to me that's it makes no
sense in the world to me because I'm a
bit of a the journey as a destination
kind of person and so if I'm I think
that I'm both doing if I grow it at
enormous ly rapid pace if I push not
only myself but my team to grow as fast
as possible we're not gonna do the
quality of work that we want to do and
while we might have a higher value in
five years as a company I don't think
that the end game is to sell a Larry
Maguire I think believes the same thing
I do and a lot of people that I look
around that and I'm interested in their
careers and their lives also are people
that are interested in what they do from
and from the people they work with
day-to-day and creating an asset like a
hotel they can just get better over time
rather than say you know we live in a
time where you have hotels that they're
redone every seven years or every five
years there's a big you know big
repositioning or whatever is the most
interesting places to me just get better
as time goes on and layer upon layer to
texture upon texture get better not by
reinventing themselves every seven years
right exactly
it's it was the second title not a
pattern language time this way of
building timeless way building yeah so
you know can you have a good life and
make your and have employees who are
invested in that business and and also
keep an asset and have it you know this
is I'm gonna digress for a second but
the hotel businesses we know it today is
a result of a lot of things but we've
come to a time where most hotels are not
owned by the management company so you
have a group of owners and you have a
management company that is a brand so
from the Four Seasons to the Hilton to
you you name at the Marriott whatever it
is or in even ace those guys over there
great friends among every ace you look
at is owned by a different ownership
group and I you know you can talk all
day long about why that is a lot of
times a management company wants to say
stay asset light because the hotel
business is you know in waves so you
don't want to get caught in a downturn
owning a property so you mitigate your
risk by growing a brand and that is
that's easier or much easier when you
are a Marriott and you're gonna be the
same everywhere and you have in in there
was a there was a time in the hotel
business that every time in hotels and
those of us as consumers of hotels
wanted that because their before that
you
you know take a trip across country and
all these hotels were independent and
God knows what you might find or it
might be delightful or it might be
horrible and there was no way of judging
the quality of a place and then we got
Hilton's and Holiday Inns and what was
great is that you could you knew what to
expect you know the level of service
with a cup of Starbucks is the same
everywhere you go yeah yeah and we and
so you you can depend on that I I've
read something from I was look the other
day I was looking at some stuff about
why musicians and hotels you know why
that love story and they're
interdependent in one way or the other
and somebody was saying I don't remember
this probably Keith Moon or somebody who
was well-known for just totally trashing
hotel rooms it's like yeah it's v you
know this is the 20th [ __ ] holiday and
you know we've woken up in and just as
many days and they all look the same
anybody would be mad at it but that time
at that time began to change with you
know what we think of as a boutique
hotel or a lifestyle hotel from Schrager
to chip Connelly you know I think you
asked me about what are the next 3-5
years hold what's my plan business-wise
or Hotel growth wise and it's I feel
like I'm at such a crossroads there and
in trying to determine what's it's not
only what's best for me it's also what's
best for the company but also the people
I work with every day and so you want to
grow because you want to be able to give
the people you work with more equity
more chance for more of a chance for you
know higher fulfillment moving into
other jobs just all those things you
want to canal a natural propensity
toward growth but then the question
becomes how fast and how much and what's
what is the endgame there and in this
business I think in in this day and age
people just mindlessly want to grow and
explode the bigger you are the better
you are the more
people know about you the better but it
I think that a lot of the qualities the
apprec appreciate in day-to-day living
become lost I think one of the reasons
we're successful as a company internally
at least is because we are like a family
in some ways and so how much can you
maintain that as well
I guess the answer is I I don't want to
mindlessly grow I want to thoughtfully
grow and that may not be at the pace
that a lot of companies would want you
to grow and it's also about that in game
and I don't think my end game would be
to grow really fast in to sell the
business which is you find a lot of
brands want to do now let's sounds also
to me just based on what you've been
saying that you're a philosophical lens
through which you view your life which
is the journey is the destination is a
fundamental juxtaposition with what a
lot of external pressures would want to
impose on the business absolutely it's
so tricky no it's such a balance as and
it's a struggle in a way it is but you
know some of their their outside
pressures or inside pressures but it
it's a really good question because I'm
in the middle of it right now
and I have lots of thoughts about it but
it could go on and on and on but I do
know that I could get hit by bus
tomorrow you know and and we all could
and you're not going to care about that
IPO you know five years from now my wife
is pregnant and I can have I I'm older
and she's young enough to be pregnant
clearly and and that's a whole other
life change also again when you see you
know what I do really am a big believer
and realization mortality I mean all
those things really point me in the
direction of living a quality life with
in relationship to other people
and in those ways I think it's you find
meaning much more in a much more real
manner than you find meaning and making
a lot of money I agree
I mean money is supposed to be fuel in
an in a sense for transferring it
transmuting that into other things like
experiences and so on ostensibly right I
mean it's our money as a representation
event I'm not against money in its own
terms super important for a business and
it's super important for the people you
work with and for and all those things
it's just that means to the end you know
no it is I mean if we look at there's a
there's really fascinating book called
the biography of a dollar or the
biography of a dollar which walks
through the history of money in some
respects which becomes even more
interesting when we start looking at
more recent develops of developments
like cryptocurrency and so on but at the
end of the day at least traditionally
speaking it's a medium of exchange and
so then the question is for one exchange
for what
let me ask just a handful more questions
because I think we could have many many
more conversations and hopefully this
isn't the last we mentioned a few books
are there any other books that you have
gifted often to other people or reread a
lot yourself I'd love that you asked
that question that way because it really
puts in a different perspective it's
like not what your favorite book is it's
what you've given it his gift which I
thought about a little bit this morning
and I mean it's so clear I made it like
I didn't have an immediate answer and
then I had to think why did I do that
but um I think when I was younger and
instead of this day I sometimes gift a
book of poetry by Adrienne Rich called a
dream of common language a dream of a
common law common language yeah which
was a book written she wrote in the in
the late 70s and she's a poet that I was
trying to think why it was that book so
important to me and it's really funny
when I read Cheryl strands wild that was
one of the books that was most important
to her that she had as she
hiked the Pacific Rim that's right I
forgot about that yeah I gift a lot
slouching towards Bethlehem a book by
Joan Didion which is a collection of
essays that I love that book so much
it's a lot about how what the kind of
writing Joan Didion is doing and those
essays are both you know of the time
there's one this a about John Wayne
there's you know about California but
there's also this collection of personal
essay she does that one's called on
keeping a notebook that I go back to
again and again and I share a lot
there's one on keeping a notebook I'm
keeping a notebook there's one called
on self-respect there's one of morality
but it's a it's an awesome collection of
essays and their other books by Joan
Didion but that's when I tend to gift
the most you know the other ones I'm
sure people mentioned to you I can't
imagine they don't is when things fall
apart but Pema Chodron
does anybody recognize that has come up
I think only once and that I'm Seth I
apologize have missed tributing but he
he does recommend Pema Chodron at least
one of her audiobooks yeah but no this
was not a book that has come up a lot so
if you could explain why thanks fall
apart
I think it's been important to me I've
given to people in my life because it
had an impact on me but it's I see I
don't know I could be wrong that it was
Pema children's first shot across the
bow I mean it might have been the first
book she did I don't know if that's true
or not but it was really my introduction
into the use Pema Chodron for the those
of you who don't know it was a Buddhist
monk who became a Buddhist monk I think
probably thirty years ago when she had
when her husband she found out her
husband was having an affair and he left
her and she was left in this place of
what to do about that and she kind of
accidentally found her way into Buddhism
but to me it really revealed this
struggle we have day-to-day of when in
the face of anything loss adversity
all those kinds of things you know how
much how we tighten up and struggle or
we get angry or we get bitter or we just
continue doing the same things over and
over that doesn't necessarily work
watching TV movies is an escape drinking
even exercise sometimes that means
whatever it is we're doing and how we
always think if we would just get to
that next perfect place it would all be
okay like if we had the next job or if
we move to this new city or if we just
had this relationship it was it all be
okay and then it as it turns out when
you get to that place lo and behold on
the next horizon as you feel
uncomfortable because you need this next
thing it's really the idea of it did
again the journey is a destination being
able to - on the way to that island roll
rowing across the ocean you need to get
fun comfort in being on that boat in the
roiling sea in an idea of impermanence
II and how I think anybody who's lived
their life with loss or death or
anything of the sort
understands what a what a jolt it is to
figure to understand that things aren't
permanent and that when we do accept the
impermanence E of things and learn how
to live in the moment or on the roiling
sea and live with that discomfort it
really changed it's a life changer and
so when things fall apart I realized
just in saying all that the Joan Didion
book slouching towards Bethlehem is
taken from the same poem the Yeats poem
slouching towards Bethlehem towards
Bethlehem right oh god you're far more
litter than I am I'm failing my exam
here we'll definitely putting this fall
apart the center cannot hold it so yeah
anyway we'll put we'll put all of these
in the show notes and we've talked about
mortality a few times I've had quite a
bit of revisiting mortality in the last
few years with very close friends and
even now currently some of the
effectively family members and
I have a coin that sits on my kitchen
counter which says memento mori remember
you're going to die with iconography on
it coincidentally enough I should give
him credit made by a friend of mine here
Ryan Holliday who's an author in the
Austin area who writes a lot about stoic
philosophy which is highly compatible
with a lot of Buddhist thought and
contemplative practice in my experience
in any case do you have a favorite
favorites a weird word to use here but a
favorite failure or a failure that you
feel like taught you a lot or set you up
for later success its I felt so often
and I've been successful very often too
I think if you if it were a formative
favorite failure and again yeah you know
sometimes don't we all feel like we're
beating our head against the wall you
like you know why am i doing that same
thing over again I mean that's a whole I
think I was still doing that that's a
whole other subject but you know when I
was young when I was in high school
I was I was in there was a I think
called youth and government and you from
all over Texas and they did in other
states as well but you would learn about
government by this kind of government
thing and it came through the YMCA tour
in their words like little social clubs
and all of that but using government was
something I got involved in when I
probably when I was a sophomore junior
high school when I was a senior in high
school I ran for youth governor of the
state of Texas which was a big state but
you had to we had to run on a local
level and then you had to run in a
regional level and then you came to
state and my grandfather's at the time
is a rancher and one of the men I admire
most was at the time older and I think I
think at that point he had broken his
hip and it was in
bed-bound at home but as I ran for youth
governor I would read the paper with him
on a pretty regular daily basis if not
every other day
and discuss current events and current
issues and it was an awesome period of
time having those discussions with him
and we came here to Austin for the
recent government Week and they do that
they do it at the Capitol and they do it
in the chambers so in the Senate and in
the House of Representatives and it's
right after the the real thing has let
out and so do you it's you know really
awesome because you're in these great
big hallways and all that kind of stuff
anyway I ran for youth governor and the
night that the derry-o taking the vote
and we're staying in a hotel right over
here not far from here at all the
LaQuinta over there and I'm a staying in
a room with three friends who were there
for the party for sure I was very
serious they were there to be in Austin
and one of them had an older boyfriend
who lived here in Austin so they started
drinking in the room and I knew that we
weren't supposed to be drinking in the
room and so I left the room and went and
visited some other friends down the hall
they got caught and we got caught I got
called too you know whoever our
supervisor was and she said did you know
they were drinking and I was like yeah I
knew and I left well it turns out that
the whole thing was running on the honor
system I'm sure I knew that at the time
and because I did not report them I was
kicked out and sent home with them and
by that point they knew that I had won
the election for youth governor of state
of Texas which meant that like in the
next year you were going to go to
Nationals you made all this stuff but
instead so the morning of the
announcement you know went to the next
person in line and absolute was sent
home on a bus with them you know sitting
with them and when my mom went to report
to my grandfather of what had happened
because he was following play-by-play
he said tell Dez we're really proud of
her and to me that was
this formative moment of realizing that
there were rules and there was Authority
and you know the honor system was what
this whole system was running on and it
was a system I was you know part cog and
will and and I realized that he was
really proud of me was I grown up with
brothers and with you know a whole
community that really believed that you
didn't rat on somebody else you didn't
call somebody out you guy was right to
remove myself but I I think there was a
whole system of a belief that I grown up
with it it would been wrong just to run
and tell on somebody else I think it was
the first time that I you know over the
years and looking back at it I think
I've learned more from this thing going
wrong then I would have learned from it
going right and it was about questioning
systems in questioning values just
because somebody feed says this is the
these are the rules and this is what it
is it doesn't mean that that's really
the rules you need to incorporate you
know as a great story
what a lovely experience also not that
particular time in the capital but with
you or as your grandfather's yeah right
yeah that sounds so great I never had
that chance my my grandparents passed
all of them when I was very young really
yeah lucky that way yeah that's and
they've been we all lived in different
states so even even when they were alive
we only got to see them very briefly you
know just just a few more questions if
you had gigantic billboard
metaphorically speaking right - on which
you think I do extra so if you had an
additional billboard on which you could
put a word a quote a question anything
non-commercial it's the message to get
out to millions or billions of people
what might you put on that billboard you
know we do over down by the San Jose in
the Austin motel there is a big
billboard but of course we rented to
advertisers but on the side of there are
a couple things on the side of Jose one
is that iconic I love you so much
that people take pictures of all the
time some it's a it's a longer story but
on the backside of Joe's there is a
quote from Jack Kerouac that says don't
break your tenderness and I love that
quote I think that's a good thing for
everybody to remember don't break your
tenderness to break your tenderness yeah
I love that I've never actually heard
that before now I think it's something
we also this is right on the backside of
Joe's lawn con South Scott yes
it's and when you're in the when you're
sitting there you can see it it's kind
of blue on the on the corrugated so it
doesn't bounce out maybe we need to
repaint it but it's been there since we
opened its room I think Mexico City
Blues well I know in in a very real way
I know you you wouldn't take full credit
for this and there were macro forces at
work and so on but the fact that I the
first thing I just thought that myself
was wow I should go check that out next
time I go for a nice walk down South
Congress I mean if you had not looked
out or perhaps gazed across the street
from the Continental and taken the San
Jose upon yourself as a project who
knows what that neighborhood would look
like I mean you have played a formative
role in making it what it is that's a
big that's a big deal it is a big deal I
mean it's an interesting we could talk
for hours about that too you know I
think it's about to change yet again I
mean it would have changed and it would
have grown and everything is always
changing and neighborhoods are always
changing but you know I think we're
about to see an a home next wave of
South Congress happen
oh yeah excited to see it yeah
well Liz this is so fun and I'm really
glad that we finally had a chance to to
sit on do you have any requests of the
audience asks of the audience
suggestions of the audience anything
you'd like to say before we wrap up no
but no but I'm very excited about
getting last days of the San Jose out
there yes yes and we were just chatting
in between a brief cut that we made
about a handful of things I probably
need to be done just in terms of
clearing rights yeah music and so on so
for those people listening it might not
be immediate but we did clink
glasses so last day is sooner than never
have San Jose sooner than never
yes that is something that I think we're
both comfortable committing to and
people can find you at the Liz Lambert
on Instagram and Twitter at bunkhouse
hotels Instagram Twitter and bunkhouse
group.com definitely if you're in the
Austin area and if you have never been
to Austin for God's sake take a visit
it's it's a very cool town the
self-proclaimed but believable live
music capital of the world and it's been
really lovely spending time with you as
well it really ends Ben thank you and
for everybody listening and watching
potentially links to everything we've
discussed maybe even the dock we'll see
how much progress we make is available
on the page with show notes for this
episode and every other at tim dot log
forward slash podcast and until next
time thank you for listening and
watching
you